i want new yorkers to hear
from me directly on this
first i fully
support a woman's right to come forward
and i think it should be encouraged in
every way
i now understand that i
acted in a way that made people
feel uncomfortable
it was unintentional and i
truly and deeply apologize for it
i feel awful about
it and frankly
i am embarrassed by it
and that's not easy to say but that's
the truth
but this is what i want you to know and
i want you to know this from me
directly i never
touched anyone inappropriately i never
touched anyone inappropriately
i never days a day for politics
i wasn't elected by politicians i was
elected by the people of the state of
new york
i'm not going to resign i work for the
people of the state of new york they
elected me
and i'm going to serve the people of the
state of new york and by the way we have
a full plate
we have covid we have recovery we have
rebuilding
we have a teetering new york city we
have a terrible financial picture
we have to do vaccines so no
[Music]
i'm going to do the job the people of
the state elected me to do